suddenly a young male comes into view
pushing a baby elephant oh my god that's
a boom no no he picks it up Oh meanwhile
a female if the baby's mother I believe
comes in and tries to rescue the calf
and runs in front of him he runs after
with an erection he's chasing after the
infant's mother and backs up toward the
infant who was looking for its mother
and goes back and grabs the infant again
pushing it he still has an erection and
puts his does what we call reach over he
rests his trunk across the infant's back
which is what's done also when a male
mounts of female where we were he moved
before meanwhile there's commotion
anathema where the left one tusk is
trying to rescue the baby the male picks
up the calf and drops it again
young female tuskless female is also
there but then the mother runs past him
and the male chases after her in
observations that I've made around the
birth of a baby elephant or around
newborns young males seem to get very
excited by the the smell of a new mother
I've always found it quite fascinating
because when a baby is born the whole
family will Rumble and trumpet and
create an incredible commotion and that
commotion attracts a lot of males who
come in to seeing you know what what may
be happening in the family
maybe the sounds are similar to when
when a female is mated and and they come
in and what I've seen is that the young
males get very confused by the smell of
the mother and they they get excited
they get erections they try and mount
the female the male in question is in
his 20s and and this is the age group
that still is not able to discriminate
it seems between the smells of of a new
mother and of a receptive female the
strange as it seems
[Music]
you